>> Will Sentance: Chúng ta sẽ trải qua một phong cách học tập
điều đó sẽ đòi hỏi rất nhiều ở tất cả các bạn.
Tôi sẽ gọi từng người trong phòng một cách khá thường xuyên
để chúng tôi có thể nói về mã của mình một cách chính xác và rõ ràng nhất có thể nhưng
đầu tiên, đó là lý lịch của tôi, có Thợ mã,
Codesmith LA, chúng tôi vừa rời văn phòng này để đến một văn phòng mới tuyệt đẹp ở Venice Beach,
ở trung tâm Bãi biển Venice, bên dưới biển hiệu Venice.
Tôi không biết có ai biết nơi đó không, nhưng nó rất tốt.
Có tôi với các chị em tài năng Newberry của tôi.
Tất cả những người, thực sự,
Ersey, ở ngoài cùng bên phải, vừa bắt đầu trận chung kết của cô ấy tại Oxford.
Thường thì họ sẽ không làm một mô hình mà bạn
làm các kỳ thi trung cấp hình thành lớp cuối cùng của bạn.
Thay vào đó, điểm cuối cùng của bạn là
được sản xuất bởi hai tuần thi vào cuối toàn bộ chương trình.
Có nghĩa là bạn có thể làm những gì bạn muốn cho đến hai tuần cuối cùng đó.
Và trong hai tuần cuối cùng đó, trời ơi, đó là hai tuần tồi tệ nhất.
Tôi nhớ ba đêm liên tiếp, ngủ trước hai tiếng trước khi làm bài.
Trời ơi.
Dù sao thì, đây là một trong những người chị của tôi.
Tôi từng làm việc tại Icecom, đó là một thư viện WebRTC phổ biến và
sau đó là Gem, một công ty chuỗi khối đã hoàn thành
mọi thứ có thể có trong không gian tiền điện tử chuỗi khối.
Một công ty rất tuyệt vời với khả năng lãnh đạo xuất sắc.
Công ty rất tốt.
Được rồi, tôi điều hành Codesmith.
Rất ngắn gọn, Codesmith là gì?
Đầu tiên và quan trọng nhất, nhân tiện, một trung tâm kỹ thuật phần mềm xuất sắc.
Tôi không thể đủ căng thẳng.
Đúng vậy, cuối cùng thì Codesmith tạo ra những người có kỹ năng để đi và xây dựng
những điều họ mơ ước, được đi làm trong công ty mà họ mơ ước.
Nhưng đó không phải là mục đích và điều đó nói lên
mọi thứ chúng ta sẽ làm hôm nay.
Mục tiêu trở thành một kỹ sư vĩ đại, là có khả năng xây dựng.
Như một tác dụng phụ của điều đó, chúng tôi có cơ hội duy nhất này để làm việc
trong những vai trò thỏa mãn trí tuệ,
sáng tạo và tôi đoán ổn định, thỏa mãn về mặt tài chính.
Tôi không biết nếu điều này đã từng tồn tại trước đây.
Đó là một đặc ân tuyệt vời khi có được điều đó
đó là những gì Codesmith sản xuất, tốt nghiệp làm việc tại Google,
Amazon, PayPal, Microsoft, Oscar, được tất cả những công ty khác này.
Chỉ một phần tư nhận được các vị trí cấp cao, hầu hết nhận được các vị trí kỹ sư cấp trung.
Nhân tiện, loại vật liệu chúng ta đang thấy ngày nay là loại vật liệu
rằng sinh viên tốt nghiệp sẽ được hỏi các câu hỏi phỏng vấn trong toàn bộ thời gian.
Chúng tôi đã khảo sát học sinh tốt nghiệp một vài tuần trước, điều gì bạn nhận được hỏi về nhiều nhất?
Số một, vòng lặp sự kiện, nó hoạt động như thế nào?
Đối với các công việc cấp trung, câu hỏi số một.
Thứ hai, đóng cửa.
Làm thế nào nó hoạt động dưới mui xe?
Bây giờ phần khó của phần một có một đột phá chi tiết về kết thúc.
Chúng tôi sẽ không xem xét nó ở cùng một mức độ chi tiết, nhưng nhân tiện,
là một bản xem trước để chúng tôi hiểu các trình vòng lặp.
Chúng ta cần hiểu sâu sắc về việc đóng cửa, được rồi.
Có gì để nói?
Tôi sẽ nói rằng nó đã ở giữa.
Điều đặc biệt đối với tôi là mỗi người trong căn phòng này,
chúng tôi độc lập bất khả tri đối với lý lịch của bạn.
Và điều tương tự cũng xảy ra ở Goldsmith.
Bạn đã tốt nghiệp Princeton CS
học cùng với người không học đại học.
Và đó một lần nữa, điều tuyệt vời về kỹ thuật phần mềm.
Chúng tôi luôn tập trung vào chương trình.
Phản hồi duy nhất bạn nhận được trong các cuộc phỏng vấn là không đủ kinh nghiệm.
Mọi người đều yêu thích, nhưng đó là phản hồi mạnh mẽ nhất trên trái đất.
Đây là ngành duy nhất không có đủ kinh nghiệm
chúng tôi đã hỏi bạn mười câu hỏi và bạn trả lời bốn câu hỏi.
Hãy điền vào sáu trong vài ngày tới, và đó là lý do cuối cùng
trở thành một kỹ sư là khả năng vượt qua các khối trong hiểu biết của bạn.
Và đó là một ngành công nghiệp vô cùng mạnh mẽ.
Nơi bạn có thể đi từ không có đủ kinh nghiệm, chỉ ba ngày sau
có đủ kinh nghiệm vì bạn đã vượt qua những khối đó.
Và đó là luận văn của Thợ mã.
Được rồi, tốt.
Đội ngũ giúp Codesmith trở nên khả thi, những người rất tốt bụng này.
Ặc.
Gửi lời chào đến Eric.
Phim của ai, anh ấy có một dự án phụ,
một bộ phim có tên là Midnight Sun, nhắm đến đối tượng thanh thiếu niên,
có ngân sách 10 triệu đô la, đã phá vỡ 25 triệu đô la trên toàn cầu.
Thật không thể tin được phải không?
Anh ấy hiện là bạn thân của Justine Bieber, người có mặt tại hội nghị hàng đầu.
Nhưng tuy nhiên, tôi nghĩ anh ta có, anh ta có thể có số của Bieb.
Tôi không chắc.
Nhưng đây là một tập hợp tuyệt vời của những người mà anh ấy làm Codesmith.
LA và New York.
Hai địa điểm xảy ra.
Những con người tuyệt vời.
Snow ở đó, người điều hành kỹ thuật ở LA, 20 năm kinh nghiệm.
Dù sao những người tuyệt vời.
Tốt.
Nhân tiện, những thứ chúng tôi tìm kiếm ở các ứng viên Thợ mã,
chỉ cần bạn quan tâm, nhưng tôi sẽ nói có ý nghĩa hơn với mọi người.
Những điều mà các công ty tìm kiếm ở các ứng viên kỹ thuật của chính họ.
Không phải nhà phát triển cấp dưới, không phải cấp mới, mà là cấp trung hoặc cấp cao.
Đó là khả năng lấy bất kỳ tính năng mới nào.
Và thực hiện nó.
Điều đó yêu cầu những gì?
Giải quyết vấn đề, đó là điều cơ bản.
Tôi có thể vượt qua một khối không?
Chú ý thứ năm quan trọng nhất là kiến ​​thức của bạn về ngôn ngữ hoặc khuôn khổ.
Những thứ đó, chúng phát triển.
Bạn James của chúng tôi ở đây đã nhận xét.
Các khung công tác front-end, chúng phát triển như một Reshe mới?
Đó là một từ?
Tôi đã lên tiếng.
Chắc chắn rồi.
Là khung boojey mới, và đó cũng không phải là từ mà tôi đang tìm kiếm.
Reshe, Rishie, tôi chắc chắn đó là một từ.
Có một người mới, một người nào đó sẽ có.
Đó là một từ.
Tôi đã không nghe từ đó trong bảy năm thiếu niên.
70 năm.
Mới về khuôn khổ xu hướng hàng năm, đó không phải là điều tạo nên một kỹ sư tuyệt vời,
bạn là một kỹ thuật viên, trong trường hợp đó.
Bạn là một kỹ thuật viên góc cạnh, bạn không linh hoạt.
Nhân tiện, điều gì tạo nên một kỹ sư tuyệt vời, những gì chúng tôi tìm kiếm
trong Code Smith, các ứng cử viên là khả năng vượt qua các khối của bạn.
Chúng tôi sẽ làm điều đó ngày hôm nay và bạn đang giao tiếp kỹ thuật.
Hôm nay khi tôi kêu gọi mọi người trong phòng này nói chuyện thông qua mã của bạn,
những gì chúng tôi đang làm là cải tiến giao tiếp kỹ thuật của chúng tôi.
Được rồi, đó là những gì chúng tôi đang làm.
Và sau đó thực hành tốt nhất trong cách tiếp cận và giao tiếp phi kỹ thuật của bạn.
Và ngay cả ở đây, sự kỳ vọng đang hỗ trợ lẫn nhau.
Đây không phải là môi trường để khoe khoang.
Mà đúng hơn là một môi trường để đón nhận sự phát triển của những người xung quanh bạn
đó là một bối cảnh tuyệt vời để phát triển bản thân của bạn.